This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Canon PIXMA Pro professional inkjet printers:
Exactly as you envisioned.
Each element in the periodic table has special
properties, and sometimes combining them together
gets a good result, but it's hard to do!
What if they could be combined using simple
home office equipment?
I was sent a study this week and looked at
it blankly for an hour before I really got
it.
It was about the plasmonics of metamaterials.
Yeah.
Plasmonics is the study of the interaction
between electromagnetic fields and free electrons
in metals.
Metamaterials are precisely engineered components
which have properties that wouldn't show up
in nature.
Essentially, it's how the design and engineering
of a thing can affect the behavior of electromagnetic
energy, like electricity or light.
Metamaterials can be used to create invisibility
cloaks, changing how light interacts with
a blanket of special elements, or protect
sensitive astronauts in space be changing
how cosmic radiation is absorbed or reflected.
They even built a black hole analog in a lab
using plasmonic metamaterials.
The value of the metamaterial was discovered
just after World War II when scientists and
engineers were trying to develop new technologies
to interact with radio, microwave and light
frequencies.
Today, engineers are working to use metamaterials
affect commercial, military and scientific
applications!
And thanks to a study in Advanced Optical
Materials, they don't have to use millions
of dollars of equipment to do it!
As you might imagine, creating these things
can cost millions of dollars and take months
with specialized equipment, until recently.
Carbon is one of the most common elements
on the planet; think, coal, diamonds, humans.
It's really variable, but organized into a
lattice at the molecular level?
Then you get graphene, a 1-atom thick perfect
electrical capacitor!
Roll that into tubes and it's super strong!
Layer it with copper and you get a metamaterial
-- a highly engineered structure that is 500
times stronger than the pure metal.
The best part, graphene can be printed with
a regular inkjet printer.
Engineers are problem solvers, and the faster
you can solve a problem, the more things you
can fix.
Now, thanks to researchers at the University
of Utah, metamaterials can be created using
a regular four-color inkjet printer loaded
with carbon and silver "ink."
Using that, researchers were able to build
10 different sample prototypes in a fraction
of the time of traditional manufacturing,
and the materials could be tested against
terahertz-waves to ensure they block and reflect
them JUST right.
The researchers were pumped that a simple
inkjet printer could create super intricate
plasmonic metamaterials, which makes frickin'
sense.
Other studies have shown they can print graphene
too.
Who knew these things would be so useful!?
These researchers say the ability to create
these prototypes might revolutionize the engineering
of wireless data transmission, magnetic materials,
the sensing of biological weapons, and even
spacecraft insulation!
Speaking of inkjet printers, we’d like to
thank Canon for making this episode possible.
With Canon PIXMA Pro Professional inkjet printers,
you can expect a level of quality and accuracy
that keeps each print true to your unique
vision.
All backed by Canon's commitment to provide
professionals with fast, high quality service
you can depend on.
Do you have a question for me
and Tara?